oro verde por oro negro en pleno corazón
de la amazonía ecuatoriana la extracción
de petróleo por parte de la empresa
estadounidense Texaco galls durante
décadas cambió la vista para siempre
algunos de los más de 300 pozos y
aferraron pero el paisaje todavía está
lleno de oleoductos camiones cisterna y
refinerías Texaco lo que hizo fue aquí
en la amazonía ecuatoriana causaron un
desastre ambiental por su ambición
económica sin respetar la vida de
quienes vivimos acá para los habitantes
de la región así como para los expertos
la industria petrolera en la zona ha
sido sinónimo de pobreza y contaminación
llegándose a verter unos 60 millones de
litros de líquidos nocivos durante la
época de actividad lo que terminó
afectando a la salud de campesinos e
indígenas que habitan en la zona existe
un 130% más de desarrollo de cáncer un
111% más de infertilidad y un 150% más
de abortos la pelea judicial de más de
30 años para asumir responsabilidades
del desastre natural terminó
involucrando a altos tribunales
internacionales pero todavía hoy no hay
solución para las comunidades locales
que apelan a la concienciación y a no
dejar en la lucha Cuál es la esperanza
la lucha social entender el rol que
juega la amazonía en el equilibrio del
clima en el mundo y defenderla en
paralelo el gobierno de Guillermo lasso
apostó por redoblar las actividades
petroleras en las zonas en activo con el
objetivo de extraer un millón de
barriles diarios